Bayern dem südlichen Nachbarn wo heute
ebenso gewählt wird sind es neinhalb
Millionen Wahlberechtigte auch hier
lockten die milden Temperaturen die
Menschen ins Freie im Sitz des
Bayerischen Landtags dem Maximilianeum
haben wir unser Wahlstudio aufgebaut für
einen spannenden Wahlabend im
ZDF so und dazu begrüßen wir Sie sehr
herzlich eine Doppelwahl zwei Flächen
Hessen und Bayern in unserem zentralen
Wahlstudio hier in München laufen heute
aus beiden Ländern die Daten ein
präsentieren wir die Hochrechnungen der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen ein Wahltermin
der zur Halbzeit der ampelregierung in
Berlin besonders interessant ist neben
der Frage Matthias wer in München oder
Wiesbaden dann das Rennen macht ja und
dabei werden es die ampelparteien SPD
Grüne und FDP schwer haben der Blick der
Wählerinnen und Wähler auf die Politik
insgesamt ist zunehmend kritisch was
heißt das für Bayern und Hessen die CSU
regiert bisher mit den freien wähln die
CDU in Hessen mit den Grünen und beides
könnte wohl fortgesetzt werden weiter so
wird das also die Botschaft des Tages
das wäre so einfach denn in beiden
Ländern steht das Thema Zuwanderung weit
oben und eine Mehrheit sagt wir können
die vielen Flüchtlinge nicht mehr
verkraften so kompliziert es ist
Lösungen zu finden so sehr scheinen die
einfachen Forderungen der AFD zu
verfangen abschieben grenzenicht machen
Baster dass die Partei in weiten Teilen
rechtsextrem ist hält viele nicht mehr
davon ab sie zu wählen ihr winkten
deutliche Zugewinne in beiden Ländern
möglich also dass sich unter der
Oberfläche der weiterso Normalität
einiges verschiebt möglich pünktlich um
18 Uhr die Prognose der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen für beide Länder die Ausgangslage
können wir uns bis dahin etwas genauer
anschauen und beginnen mit
Hessen schwarzgrün regiert seit bald 10
Jahren wird das so weitergehen CDU
Ministerpräsident Boris rin stellt sich
hier erstmals zur Wahl und hat eine
prominente Herausforderin bekommen mehr
zu Themen und Köpfen des wahlkamps in
Hessen Matthias
[Musik]
kubitzer herrliches
Hessen neben der Postkarte aber auch
große
Probleme bei einer Reise durchs Land der
Romantik und
Märchen auch
Horrortrips auf Frankfurter
Straßen und Krisenstimmung bis in die
höchsten Etagen das wirtschaftsstarke
Geberland versucht Anschluss zu halten
muss sich
erneuern und den Wandel wuppen das
drängendste Thema der Hessen aber bei
dieser Wahl die
Migration sch ist Obergrenze erreicht
und wir sind drüber ich glaube wir sind
verpflichtet zu helfen aber in der Art
und Weise wie es geschieht ist es
unverantwortlich und wer macht sie für
die Zukunft fit wenn auch die Schulen am
Anschlag sind Thema Bildung ist
natürlich ein riesiger Punkt den man
wahrscheinlich am ehsten verbessern
müsste vor allem muss es schneller gehen
wir brauchen die Lehrkräfte jetzt es
muss für querinsteige attraktiver
gestaltet werden manche Lehrer haben
auch gar keine Ahnung was sie machen
sind auch neu an der Schule wissen
genauso viel wie wir aber und jetzt die
Kandidaten Ministerpräsident Boris rin
stellt sich das erste Mal den Wählern
und kommt wohl sicher als Erster ins
Ziel die CDU klar V seine Strategie die
ampelangst eine Ampel ist immer möglich
in der Schwankungsbreite von solchen
Umfragen und deswegen muss man wirklich
um die letzte Stimme auch noch kämpfen
trotz prominentem Gesicht die SPD wohl
erfolglos in Hessen nennt sie fer droht
Platz 3 ich würde meiner Partei immer
Konstellationen empfehlen wo wir viele
sozialdemokratische Themen umsetzen
können in welcher Konstellation das auch
immer dann ist Wirtschaftsminister Tarek
gvasier wäre gern grüner ampelchef weil
ich ein Plan für dieses Land habe und
dafür brenne ihn auch in die Tat
umzusetzen die AFD stärker aber ohne
Machtoption wir würden uns hier in die
Pflicht neben lassen und mit der CDU
eine Koalition eingeen die FDP scharf an
der 5% Hürde wir streben eine Koalition
mit der CDU und der SPD an die
sogenannte deutschlandkoalition die
Linke relativ sicher unter 5% ich glaube
einfach dass die Beziehung zwischen den
Menschen und der Linken da ein bisschen
gestört ist weil viele gar nicht mehr
wissen wofür steht die Linke eigentlich
mit Boris rin wird der alte woh der neue
sein spannend in Hessen wer kommt auf
Platz
2 tja ist die spannende Frage in Hessen
genau genommen in unserem Wahlstudio in
Wiesbaden hält heute Abend Peter Wagner
die Stellung der als ZF Studioleiter
dort den Wahlkampf intensiv verfolgt hat
und vor dem häsischen Landtag begrüße
ich ihn jetzt auch Peter seit fast 10
Jahren wird Hessen schwarzgrün regiert
weiter so oder Wechsel ist die Frage
gab's denn in Hessen im Wahlkampf sowas
wie
Wechselstimmung eine richtige
Wechselstimmung habe ich hier im
Wahlkampf eigentlich nicht beobachtet
die Union hat ja mit Boris rein
rechtzeitig auf ein neues Gesicht
gesetzt und es ist ja gelungen ihn in 16
Monaten doch schon relativ bekannt zu
machen und auch er ist auch relativ
beliebt also wenn man über
Wechselstimmung reden kann dann
allenfalls in kleinen Teilen der Union
die würden es vielleicht gerne mal mit
einem anderen Koalitionspartner als den
Grünen probieren da gibt's durchaus
welche die sagen vielleicht mal mit der
SPD eine Kroko Wagen jetzt ist mit Nancy
Felser für die SPD eine prominente
Bundesministerin angetreten allerdings
ja mit Rückfahrticket nach Berlin nehmen
die Wähler ihr das übel ich glaube das
Rückfahrtticket selbst nicht das hat sie
ja klar und deutlich und sehr früh
kommuniziert aber ihr Wahlkampf war
nicht wirklich gelungen da fehlt es an
der klaren Strategie es gab eine Menge
kleine und auch zwei drei große Fehler
und Pannen im Wahlkampf und das hat
einfach nicht gut funktioniert und die
große Frage wird sein was kommt dann
wenn neny Feser wieder zurück ist in
Berlin was wird aus der hessischen SPD
und bleibt sie dann auch häsische SPD
Vorsitzende vielen Dank Peters im
hessischen Landtag heute Abend bis
später wir haben natürlich auch unsere
Reporterinnen und Reporter in Hessen im
Einsatz die uns Erwartungen Stimmungen
bei den Parteien jetzt und im Verlauf
des Abends schildern werden beginnen wir
bei Isabelle de laweger die ein genauen
Blick auf die AFD Hessen heute abend
werfen wird bei der letzten Wahl 2018
mit gut 13% in den Wiesbadener Landtag
eingezogen stärker ist die Partei in
keinem anderen westdeutschen Land und
traut sich Isabelle jetzt noch mehr zu
genauo ist es mindestens 15 bis 17%
möchte die AFD diesmal in Hessen holen
vor allem aber will sie die Nummer 2 im
hessischen Landtag werden und damit
stärkste
Oppositionsfraktion sie ist sehr sehr
selbstbewusst aufgetreten im Wahlkampf
gestern erst beim Abschluss in Wiesbaden
hat Andreas lichert seinen Anhängern
zugerufen lasst uns die FDP aus dem
Parlament werfen und mit 20 Abgeordneten
in den Landtag einziehen ob das dann
aber stattfindet und so sein kann oder
Wunschdenken bleibt das gehört zu den
spannendsten Fragen des Abends danke
schön Isabelle und weiter gehen wir zu
Inken Klinge und zur FDP ja die
Liberalen müssen zittern seit den 80er
Jahren immer im häsischen Landtag
vertreten beim letzten Mal waren es
7,5% heute könnte es knapp werden Inke
wie ist die Stimmung na ja also ganz
ehrlich ist hier noch nicht so viel los
man sieht die Stimmung sieht definitiv
anders aus im Wahlkampf waren es viele
junge die den Spitzenkandidaten der FDP
Stefan naras unterstützt haben der
wünscht sich eine deutschlandkoalition
also schwarzrotgelb er möchte die Grünen
gerne raushaben aus dem Landtag ob das
allerdings gelingen kann ist sehr sehr
fraglich er ist bis zum Schluss durchs
Land getourt hat für Stimmen geworben
denn ihm ist natürlich klar es wird ganz
ganz knapp hier in Hessen und jede
Stimme
zählt ja danke Inken so ist es
interessant ist dass die vorumfragen die
Freien Wähler in Hessen relativ stark
sahen auch darauf werden wir schauen
heute abend jetzt aber gucken wir an die
Spitze Ministerpräsident Boris rin
stellt sich wie wir gesehen haben
erstmals dem Votum der Wähler hat aber
gleich zwei Herausforderer in der
Projektion führt die CDU sehr deutlich
aber wollen die Hessen Matthias Boris
rein denn auch wirklich als Landesvater
behalten ja das wollen sie aber sein
Vorsprung fällt sehr unterschiedlich aus
je nach nachdem nach welchem
Gegenkandidaten oder welcher
Gegenkandidatin man fragt 50% sehen wir
hier wollen das Boris rin
Ministerpräsident bleibt aber immerhin
31% wollen Tarek alvasir den
Spitzenkandidaten der Grünen viel größer
ist der Abstand auf die SPD
Spitzenkandidatin Nancy fäer Boris rin
61% und Nancy fäer
21% insgesamt wird sie hier in Hessen
sehr schlecht bewertet und wie sehen die
Hessen die Parteien und ihre Kompetenz
das schauen wir uns hier an welche
Partei kann die Probleme am ehsten lösen
33% sagen CDU das ist der beste aber
kein überragender Wert 12 das können die
Grünen ebenso viele SPD 10% AFD aber 12%
sagen das kann keine Partei und 13 %
wissen es nicht da sieht man eine
gewisse
Ratlosigkeit ja danke schön Matthias ja
wir fragen nach bei den Parteien
zunächst bei den Grünen die efering für
uns beobachtet heute abend ich beim
letzten mal sehr stark dazu gewonnen das
beste Ergebnis für die Grünen in Hessen
worauf stellen Sie sich jetzt ein auf
einen Dämpfer für grüne Politik im Bund
ja man ist trotzdem zuversichtlich
eigentlich wollten die Grünen die CDU ja
in der Staatskanzlei ablösen mit ihrem
Spitzenkandidaten Tarik alvasir dessen
arabischer Name übrigens für der
Minister steht Wirtschaftsminister ist
er seit knapp 10 Jahren
Ministerpräsident würde er gerne werden
doch die Grünen kamen im Wahlkampf nicht
so richtig aus dem St Block sicherlich
wirken die ampelquirelen unter Streit
ums heizungsgesetz wie eine Art
Bleiweste auch wenn der pragmatische
alvasir sich immer wieder vom
ampelzirkus wie er sagte distanzierte ja
hier ist man dennoch zuversichtlich sind
viele junge Leute und sie hoffen auf
Platz 2 vor der SPD und auf eine
Fortsetzung der schwarzgrünen Regierung
hier in Hessen danke schön
die Grünen wollen weiter regieren hören
wer die SPD will das wieder tun in
Hessen das ja große sozialdemokratische
Zeiten erlebt hat die 80er mit Holger
bner z.B in den 90ern gab es den
Ministerpräsidenten Hans Eichel an diese
Zeiten will nen sie Feler anknüpfen als
bundesinnenministerin in der
ampelregierung setzt sie auch für Hessen
auf eine Ampel aber RAL Schipanski bei
der SPD in Wiesbaden ihr Wahlkampf hat
nicht recht gezündet worauf stellen sich
die Sozialdemokraten
ein ja bettiner die SPD hat sich
sinnigerweise einen Laden rausgesucht
der das Wohnzimmer heißt lässig geht zu
launchig auch aber gemütlich wird dieser
Abend nicht zumindest nicht für Nancy
fer ihr Credo war immer sie bleibt nur
wenn sie Ministerpräsidentin wird aber
danach sieht's nicht aus laut Umfragen
ist sogar die Gefahr groß dass sie das
schlechteste Ergebnis aller Zeiten für
die SPD einfahren wird und so stellt
sich dann die Frage was bleibt an diesem
Abend wenn es so kommen sollte wie
beschädigt fährt Sie zurück nach Berlin
und was bleibt von der SPD hier in
Hessen die zurückgelassen wird übrig das
Minimalziel so ist zu hören heute Abend
ist zumindest vor der AFD zu liegen und
vielleicht sich anzubieten als
Juniorpartner in einer Koalition mit der
CDU und aus beiden kann man rauslesen
ein rauschendes Fest wird das hier heute
Abend nicht vielen Dank Ralf ja und zum
Abschluss unseres hässischen
reporterreigens gehen wir zur CDU
genauso wie die SPD hatte die CDU vor 5
Jahren sehr stark verloren zweistellige
Verluste Stefan scher bei der CDU wie
viel traut man dem neuen
Ministerpräsidenten rin denn zu davon
wieder aufzuholen
ja hier bei der CDU ist man in freudiger
Erwartung würde ich das mal nennen der
Vorsprung in den Umfragen war so klar
und so stabil dass alle fest davon
ausgehen dass Boris Rhein und die CDU
hier der Gewinner der Wahl sein werden
vielleicht sogar mit 30% plus X so ist
die Hoffnung und das würde natürlich
auch bedeuten dass Boris rin als
Ministerpräsident der zum ersten Mal
einen Wahlkampf bestreitet deutlich vor
seinem deutlich ein deutlich besseres
Ergebnis erzielen würde als ein
Vorgänger Volker bofier der bei der
letzten Mal 27% geholt hat das würde
Boris Rhein den Rücken stärken sowohl in
der Partei als auch in anstehenden
Koalitionsverhandlungen und da
wahrscheinlich dann mit den Grünen oder
mit der SPD da könnte sich die CDU den
Koalitionspartner quasi aussuchen danke
schön Stefan und bei uns ist wie immer
Professor K Rudolf Korte schönen guten
Abend guten Abend so eine Doppelwahl das
ist natürlich per se schon interessant
zumal wenn es auf der Hälfte einer
Legislaturperiode im Bund ist aber wir
bleiben mal zunächst noch bei Hessen
seit 10 Jahren regiert die CD mit den
Grünen nun hat aber die CDU im Bund ja
die Grünen Friedrich märz zum Hauptfeind
erklärt welche Auswirkungen könnte das
haben ja die CDU war in Hessen ganz
offenbar einer doppelten
Auseinandersetzung ausgesetzt einmal
natürlich gegen die Ampel und dann ein
teilweise auch gegen den eigenen
Vorsitzenden denn die CDU regiert
erfolgreich nach ihrer eigenen Sicht und
vor allen Ding geräuschlos wie man
wahrnimmt seit vielen Jahren ja
erfolgreich mit den Grünen zusammen also
wir werden sehen wie wie das da
weitergeht das Thema Migration
Einwanderung stand hier wie übrigens
auch in Bayern ganz oben hat die
Menschen sehr beschäftigt das hätte doch
eigentlich SPD-Kandidatin Felser
Auftrieb geben müssen stattdessen
dümpelt die SPD im Wahlkampf eher vor
sich hin ja wenn sie es in Ansätzen
gelöst hätte oder Lösungsmodelle
vorgestellt hätte ist aber offenbar
nicht der Fall und für viele Bürger
kommt das Thema auch zu arrogant
formuliert daher sie fühlen sich nicht
aufgehoben und auch nicht verstanden ist
ja nicht die Frage wie man gegen
Fremdheit ist sondern vor allen Dingen
wie man offenbar von der Politik
behandelt wird das ist ein Thema was mit
Migration zusammenspielt und damit auch
Staatsversagen staatsfrust ein Amalgam
unterschiedlicher Störung also
Besonderheiten im Lande Hessen vielen
Dank Professor Korte für den Moment wir
gucken mal auf die Uhr eine gute
Viertelstunde haben wir bis zur Prognose
dann kommen wir nämlich jetzt von Hessen
zu Bayern auch hier ist die Frage weiter
so wie bisher CSU Ministerpräsident
Söder möchte mit den Freien Wählern
weiter regieren denn anders als sein
Kollege in Hessen hat er eine
Zusammenarbeit mit den Grünen
ausgeschlossen kategorisch zur
Ausgangslage in Bayern Matthias
[Musik]
kubitzer wunderschönes
Bayern neben dem Kitsch das echte
Leben beim ersten Blick auf den
Freistaat aber tatsächlich viel
Postkarte von
Oberfranken bis zum Nebelhorn wählen wo
andere Urlaub machen dort wo tatsächlich
einiges besser läuft als im Rest der
Republik bayerischer stolz auf Wohlstand
und
Tradition geht's uns gut in Bayern ja
wer kommen nach uns mit Abstand würberg
und dann kommt lang nich oder die gewis
Zeit dass es immer weiter aufwärts geht
bröckelt aber auch in Bayern gebrochene
Versprechen sorgen für
Frust man hat zwar einen rechtlichen
Anspruch auf einen kiterplatz aber die
Realität sieht leider anders aus
Gesundheitspolitik eine absolute
Katastrophe da muss dringend was gemacht
werden nicht blo hier zu den Kandidaten
Markus Söder will mit ihm weiter
regieren Hubert eiwanger von den Freien
Wählern söers CSU zwar deutlich vorn
aber längst nicht so stark wie der
eigene Anspruch er muss also kämpfen
gibt sich
breitbeinig komm im Endeffekt auf die
Frage an der Stabilität einer Regierung
und das stabile starke Teil das merkt
man ja an allen Dingen das ist natürlich
die CSU und das ist vor allem auch der
Ministerpräsident eiwanger durch die
flugblatffäre von der Vergangenheit
eingeholt von Söder aber nicht
rausgeschmissen will heute profitieren
ich habe nur meine persönliche
Wahrnehmung dass die Menschen uns
diesmal noch mehr Stimmen geben wohlne
bei der letzen laag die Grünen ohne
Machtoption weil Söder nicht mit ihnen
will wir brauchen eine Staatsregierung
mit Anstand mit einer klaren Kante gegen
Antidemokraten die AFD stärker als beim
letzten Mal aber isoliert wer Freien
Wähler wählt der wählt ein weiter so der
Regierung Söder und das wollen die
Menschen hier in Bayern nicht die SPD
unter ferner liefen Bull wieder
einstellig Rechtspopulismus hilft Bayern
hilft den Menschen überhaupt nicht
weiter SPD stehen für vernünftige
Politik die FDP wohl nicht mehr im
Landtag ich bin überzeugt es braucht
eine liberale Stimme die sich für
Marktwirtschaft für Freiheit für
Eigenverantwortung einsetzt und auch für
die Grundrechte der Bürger die spannende
Frage in Bayern passt am Ende für Söder
also gewinnt oder verliert die CSU im
Vergleich zum letzten
Mal Stefan leifert ist unser
Studioleiter in Bayern Stefan wie hast
du diesen Wahlkampf erlebt der ja durch
diese Flug Affäre rund um eiwange auch
bundesweite Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat
ja das war auch für uns Beobachter hier
ein Wahlkampf voller Überraschung und
ganz unterschiedlicher Phasen Phase 1
war eher LAH und inhaltsleer dann kam
Phase 2 die eiwangerffäre die alles
dominiert hat und dann kamen die letzten
drei Wochen dieses Wahlkampfs dominiert
vom Thema Migration obwohl die CSU das
eigentlich gar nicht so geplant hatte
was ich aber durch den ganzen Wahlkampf
zieht ist ein kleines Kunststück was
Markus Söder hier gelungen ist er ist
der amtierende Ministerpräsident und hat
gleich wohl einen oppositionswahlkampf
geführt gegen Berlin gegen die
ampelparteien vor allem gegen die Grünen
und hat das hat den bayerischen
Oppositionsparteien hier kaum Luft
gelassen für eigen Themen also es ging
hauptsächlich um Berlin und um Bayern
nur am Rande und der ist ja mit der CSU
mal gestartet mit dem Ziel 40 + X also
wieder aufholen besser werden als beim
letzten Mal jetzt hat man das Gefühl es
geht nur noch ums halten von 37%. das
war interessant zu beobachten in den
letzten Tagen und Monaten da hat die
parteistrategie oder die Parteistrategen
ganz emsig
erwartungsmanagement nach unten
Betrieben erst hieß es hätte man vor
zwei Monaten sich wahrscheinlich in der
CSU noch drauf einigen können 40 plus X
ist das Ziel dann war es das Ergebnis
vom letzten Mal also 37 inzwischen wird
gar keine Zahl mehr genannt da wäre man
zufrieden wenn man einfach nur regieren
kann und stärkste Kraft wird also das
ist schon ein Prozess der Normalisierung
auch hier in Bayern danke schön Stefan
leifert für den Moment so ich schaue auf
die uhr wir haben gut 10 Minuten bis zur
Prognose die wollen wir und können wir
nutzen um die Stimmung auch bei den
Parteien in Bayern auszuloten und wir
beginnen bei der SPD seit 66 Jahren in
der Opposition das ist hier die aspora
beim letzten Mal erlebte sie dann aber
zudem ein echtes disaster Absturz auf
einen einstelligen Wert unter 10 das
will man jetzt wieder aufholen zumindest
ein bisschen aber Linda kirsern die
Zeichen stehen nicht gut
dafür ja in der Tat eben sagte jemand
auf der SPD Wahlparty die Stimmung sei
besser als die Umfrage und die sahen ja
wirklich lange nicht gut aus demnach
könnte das hier heute Abend wirklich ein
bitterer Abend werden das Ziel lautet
aber Hauptsache besser als vor 5 Jahren
damals gab es 9,7% aus Sicht der SPD
natürlich eine Katastrophe und so hatte
man hier auch auf einen Effekt gehofft
den wir von der Bundestagswahl 2021
kennen auch damals war es nicht
besonders gut für die SPD eine ganze
Weile lang und heute stellt die Partei
den Bundeskanzler aber diese Art von
Überraschungseffekt die konnte man in
den Umfragen nicht lesen und könnte das
eben ein bitterer Abend werden der
Wahlkampf war schwierig es gab kaum
gewinnbringenden Rückendeckung aus
Berlin die SPD muss einfach hoffen dass
sie heute besser abschneidet als vor 5
Jahren danke schön Linda und wir gehen
weiter zu den Grünen die die großen
Gewinner waren beim letzten Mal Markus
Söder hat ordentlich antigrünen
Wahlkampf gemacht vor allem mit Blick
auf grüne Regierungspolitik in Berlin WF
schmiese wie groß ist jetzt die Sorge
bei den Grünen dass das verf verfängt
groß ist die Sorge und die Stimmung hier
ist ein bisschen resignativ ich war vor
5 Jahren hier und das war viel voller
die standen Rücken an Rücken und dann
kam der damalige noch Parteichef Robert
habbeck und wurde getragen wie ein
Popstar wirklich getragen von den Leuten
auf Händen hier und jetzt hat man den
Eindruck schielen die wirklich mit
anderen Augen nach Berlin die
bayerischen Grünen und sind nicht sehr
dankbar für die Unterstützung aus Berlin
die unfreiwillige Unterstützung mit
heizungsgesetz Wärmepumpe und vielen
anderen also die Hoffnung ist groß dass
man zweitstärkste Kraft im Landtag
bleibt klar ist man wird nicht regieren
weil Söder es nicht will und was auch
sein kann dass man runterrutscht von
Platz 2 auf Platz 4 und das hätte
natürlich auch Folgen im Landtag was
Ausschüsse angeht und alles also
insofern resignative Stimmung und ein
bisschen Aufregung wo landet man danke
schön woh für die Eindrücke aus dem
Stand zweistellig wurde die AFD bei der
letzten Wahl in Bayern und zog mit 10 2%
in den Landtag ein nach den Formfragen
kann sie jetzt mit zugewinnen rechnen
Patrizia was rechnet sich die AFD aus in
Bayern ja Bettina also nach den letzten
Umfragen kann die AFD locker über dieses
Ergebnis vom letzten Mal kommen die
Umfrageinstitute sehen die AFD in Bayern
bei ungefähr 14% die AFD selbst hat als
Wahlziel ausgegeben stärkste
Oppositionskraft werden zu wollen und
dafür würde der Partei auch der Platz 3
reichen hinter den Regierenden CSU und
Freien Wählern die Stimmung hier
freudige Anspannung man rechnet mit
einem guten Ergebnis aus der
Parteiführung hier in Bayern ist zu
hören 13,5% wäre schon gut aber man
würde sich lieber 15 wünschen vielen
Dank Patrizia und dann sind wir bei den
Regierungsparteien CSU Freie Wähler die
flugblatffäre wir haben es gehört hat
das Verhältnis belastet und zunächst mal
mal die Freien Wähler gestärkt eine
Fieberkurve der Solidarität hat das
Markus Söder im heute journal genannt
Matthias das Söder das Rennen macht da
besteht eigentlich kein Zweifel aber wie
steht er da wie steht's um seinen
Amtsbonus na ernsthafte Konkurrenz hat
Söder tatsächlich nicht einerseits weil
seine CSU in den Umfragen deutlich vorne
liegt andererseits weil er als
Ministerpräsident ziemlich unangefochten
ist auf die Frage wen hätten sie lieber
als Ministerpräsidenten hier in Bayern
sagen 56% Marus Söder nur 15% ludg
Hartmann das ist der
kpitzenkandidat der Grünen hier im Land
Katharina Schulze die zweite im Grünen
Bunde kann nach der bayerischen
Verfassung nicht Ministerpräsidentin
werden weil sie noch nicht 40 Jahre alt
ist im Wahlkampf hat die flugblattaffäre
hohe Wellen geschlagen wie wirkt sich
das aus die war hilfreich für die Freien
Wähler sagen 43% oder glauben das 40%
glauben es spielt keine Rolle und nur
13% sagen das hat den Freien Wählern
geschadet okay danke schön Matthias
interessante Zahlen und wir sehen haben
6 Minuten bis zur Prognose da lohnt dann
noch der Blick zu unseren Reportern bei
den Regierungsparteien jutter sonnewald
die Freien Wähler können mit zugewinnen
rechnen und wollen das Rennen gegen die
Grünen umplatz Z gewinnen wie ist die
Stimmung die Stimmung hier ist gut der
Saal ist rappelvoll und viele sind schon
gewappnet mit freien wählerfähnchen denn
die Freien Wähler können davon ausgehen
dass sie hier besser abschneiden werden
dieses dieses Mal als vor 5 Jahren bei
der Wahl und Sie können auch fest davon
ausgehen dass sie wieder mitreieren
werden die Sache ist nur die Frage ist
hier nur wie gut werden sie abschneiden
den davon wird abhängen welche
Forderungen sie stellen können aus der
CSU Spitze ist immerhin schon zu hören
dass man Hubert eiwanger den fizze nicht
mehr als fizze haben möchte als Reaktion
auf diese flugblattaffäre und man sieht
ihn auch nicht als Repräsentanten der
der bayerischen Regierung im Ausland ob
das so kommt und ob es so kommen kann
das hängt natürlich auch ab von der
Stärke wie sie hier abschneiden und auch
welche und wie viele Ministerien sie
hier fordern
können ja danke schön Jutta mit
interessanten Einblicken und zum Schluss
gehen wir zur CSU beim letzten Mal waren
das
37,2% das war ein Schock für die Partei
ein historisch schlechter Wert Alexander
pull wie ist die Erwartung heute wäre
halten schon ein
Erfolg ja in der Tat man hofft hier sehr
stark eigentlich dass man ein besseres
Ergebnis erzielt als bei der Wahl
2018 aber ob das funktioniert das steht
wirklich in den Sternen für die CSU für
Markus Söder selbst geht es eigentlich
um zwei Fragen einmal kann er weiter
regieren mit den Freien Wählern das
scheint nach den Umfragen möglich zu
sein auf der anderen Seite wenn das
Ergebnis für die CSU aber wesentlich
schlechter ist als 2018 dann könnte ihn
das natürlich auch als Parteichef
Schwächen mittelfristig muss man dazu
sagen weil es stehen ja wahrscheinlich
Koalitionsverhandlungen dann an relativ
bald mit den Freien Wählern natürlich
wird es keine parteiinterne Diskussion
geben natürlich wird die CSU Markus
höder nicht Schwächen in solche
Koalitionsverhandlungen schicken also
für Markus höder geht es um zwei Fragen
einmal weiter regieren aber auch wie er
als csuf liefern kann danke schön
Alexander Pool ja und das können wir
gleich noch vertiefen mit Professor
Korte 4 Minuten bis zur Prognose
Professor Korte eine Schicksalswahl für
die CSU hat Markus Söder diese Wahl
schon genannt irgendwie ist es auch für
ihn eine Schicksalswahl ja man hat den
Eindruck weil es vielleicht von den
Daten her darauf hindeutet dass es beim
letzten mal eben kein Unfall war sondern
dass man mit ihm nicht wirklich mehr
auch erringen kann also es bröckelt an
dem Nimbus einer Staatspartei
offensichtlich und so eine Gewöhnung an
das weniger wird wahrscheinlich den
Alltag hier prägen weil eben neben der
CSU auch freie Wähler und auch AFD stark
sind jetzt ne wir mal Bayern und Hessen
zusammen Professor Korte welche
bundespolitische Bedeutung haben die
Wahlen heute ist das tatsächlich auch
dann eine Botschaft ein Votum für Scholz
für Harbeck für Lindner auf jeden Fall
denn die vorherigen Umfragen deuten ja
auf eine Gerade grandiose Abstrafung der
ampelparteien hin und das wird in Berlin
ankommen sofern ist die Frage dass die
Überforderung bei vielen Menschen
offenbar dazu führt gegen die Ampel zu
votieren und auch die Auseinandersetzung
mit Transformation mit Veränderung also
veränderungserschöpfung sich auch
ausdrückt also Berlin war und ist eine
große Positionierung bei dieser Wahl
wenn wir uns dran erinnern beim letzten
Mal nach der häischen Wahl trat die
Parteivorsitzende der CDU zurück nach
dem Wahlergebnis in Wiesbaden also da
ist wirklich Musik drin heute abend
wobei Unzufriedenheit auf der Hälfte der
Legislatur bei Wählerinnen und Wählern
auch nichts ungewöhnliches ist richtig
ja also Zwischenzeugnis da geht es darum
ob man versetzungsgefährdet ist das kann
man hier schon vielleicht annehmen aber
es gibt eben auch die Möglichkeiten von
jetzt auf anders zu arbeiten und das
Ergebnis so anzunehmen daraus
Konsequenzen zu ziehen viel ha den
Eindruck dass sie auch nicht gehört
werden hier in München und nicht in
Wiesbaden und dass ein Stück weit
arrogante Kommunikation von Berlin aus
betrieben wird auch dagegen wehren sich
offenbar viele nun haben wir gesehen aus
den vorumfragen und auch aus den
Berichten unserer Reporter offenbar ist
es so dass in beiden Ländern die
ansinhaber aller Wahrscheinlichkeit nach
bestätigt werden wir werden gleich sehen
in welcher Weise trotzdem wird's ja
Verschiebungen geben wir haben
sicherlich auf die AFD zu achten die ja
stark getrommelt hat in diesem Wahlkampf
und es war ja auch durchaus ein äh
ein mit vielen populistischen Tönen ein
polarisierender Wahlkampf das stimmt
aber wir sehen vor allen zwei
unterschiedliche führungs und
Kommunikationsstile man hat hier in
München den rebellisch gerade zu
auftretenden breitbeinigen heroischen
Akteur und man hat ih Wiesbaden den
präsidialen Kümmerer der postheroisch
Auftrag also ganz unterschiedliche
Akteure schaffen es offenbar eine
Mehrheit noch hinter sich zu bringen und
sollten no nicht vergessen vermutlich ja
über 30% so sind die vorherigen
umfragendaten ja zu interpretieren das
ist europaweit einmalig es deutet darauf
hin Amtsinhaber vermutlich zu bestätigen
mit einer Größen Ordnung die in anderen
Ländern wie traumergebnisse klingen in
anderen Ländern in den ostdeutschen
Ländern ist die AFD hochgeschossen auch
im Bund im Trend in den Umfragen sehr
hoch und wir werden sehen ob sich das
auch bei diesen Wahlen jetzt auszeichnet
und auswirkt vielen Dank Professor Korte
für den Moment wir werden Zeit haben die
Wahlergebnisse die Prognose und
hochrechnungsergebnisse intensiv zu
besprechen also worauf haben sie zu
achten die Ampel bekommt sie ein ein
Denkzettel wie geht das Rennen um Rang 2
aus in beiden Ländern ist das spannend
wie hoch etwa kommt die AFD die Prognose
der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen für beide
Länder in 5 Sekunden wir werden mit
Bayern gewinnen beginnen 18 Uhr die
Prognose der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen für
Bayern die CSU kommt auf
36,5 leichte Verluste schlechtestes
Ergebnis seit den 50er Jahren die Grünen
15,5 das sind ebenfalls Verluste die
Freien Wähler mit 14
Zugewinne die AFD 16 deutliche Zugewinne
sind das SPD 8,5 das schlechteste
Ergebnis in einem westlichen Bundesland
die FDP 3 Verluste und nicht mehr im
Landtag andere
6,5 so dann kommen wir zu Hessen die CDU
34,5 das sind deutliche Gewinne 7,5%
Punkte grüne 15,5 starke Verluste SPD 15
ebenfalls starke Verlust und das
schlechteste Ergebnis in Hessen AFD 17
deutliche Gewinne bestes Ergebnis in
einem westlichen Bundesland FDP 5
Verluste unklar ob sie die 5% Hörde
wirklich nimmt linke 3,5 mit Verlusten
Freie Wähler 3,5 andere zusammen se so
das ist die Prognose für Bayern und für
Hessen und wir sehen danach wäre die AFD
in beiden Ländern auf Rang 2 wir wollen
jetzt natürlich sehen was das für Sitze
und Hochrechnungen bedeutet und all das
von Matthias vnof beginnend mit Bayern
so sieht's aus bertina wir schauen mal
wie der Bayerische Landtag sich nach
dieser Prognose zusammensetzen würde wir
kommen auf
205 Sitze gesamt im Moment diese
Gesamtzahl kann sich verändern im Laufe
des Abends das berührt aber nicht das
Kräfteverhältnis also fangen wir an mit
den Parteien da kommt die CSU auf 83
Sitze die Grünen auf
35 Freie Wähler 32 AFD 36 und die SPD
auf 19 Sitze und die spannende Frage wie
immer ist natürlich welche politisch
denkbaren Koalitionen können daraus
entstehen da sehen wir die CSU und die
freien weder kämen auf 115 Sitze bei 103
bei dieser Linie liegt die absolute
Mehrheit das reicht also satt CSU und
Grüne auch das ist deutlich rüber CSU
und SPD ginge knapp nicht dass der Stand
im Moment in Bayern und wir gucken mal
nach Hessen in den Wiesbadener Landtag
da haben wir im Moment 132 Sitze das
kann sich genauso noch ändern im Laufe
des Abends und wir fangen mal an mit der
CDU 2 Sitze die Grünen
23 die SPD 23 die AFD
26 und die FDP 8 Sitze und fürs Regieren
in Hessen würde das bedeuten hier noch
mal die Linie absolute Mehrheit bei 67
in Hessen CDU und Grüne das ist die
amtierende Regierung kmen auf 75 Sitze
das reicht dicke CDU und SPD ebenfalls
und Grüne SPD und FDP würde nicht
reichen selbst wenn die FDP den Sprung
in den Landtag schafft was ja noch nicht
klar ist ja danke schön Matthias das
sind also die prognoseergebnis und die
Folgen daraus und da sehen wir schon da
ist von dem weiter so die Rede die
Kandidaten Ministerpräsidenten vorn und
könnten mit den bisherigen Partnern
weitermachen und dennoch ist natürlich
einiges im Hintergrund passiert in
Bayern und da wollen wir beginnen eine
erstarkte AFD und ein Ministerpräsident
der noch unter dem bisherigen Ergebnis
liegt dass wir die CSU Alexander Pool
alles andere als fröhlich gestimmt haben
als die Prognose kam ja das ist richtig
also was man hier gehört hat war ich
möchte mal sagen freundlicher Applaus
oder vielleicht auch erleichterter
Applaus die CSU hat ja versucht die
Erwartungen im Vorfeld der Wahl schon
runterzuschrauben Markus Söder hat immer
wieder gesagt dass es Ergebnisse von 40%
eigentlich nicht mehr gibt er hat gesagt
dass Wahlen kein Schönheitswettbewerb
sind und genau das ist es jetzt für ihn
auch nicht also er hat als
Parteivorsitzender bei der ersten Wahl
bei der er wieder angetreten ist hat er
hier verloren bei der ersten
Landtagswahl und das ist jetzt ein ein
Ergebnis für ihn das könnte ihn
natürlich mittelfristig Schwächen als
Parteivorsitzenden aber sollte es und so
sieht es ja aus zu koalitionsverhandlung
mit den freien wähln kommen dann werden
die sehr hart werden das heißt die CSU
wird den Teufel tun jetzt hier Partei
intern über Herrn Söder zu diskutieren
in damit geschwächt in diese
koalitionsverhandlung schicken also für
Markus Söder hätte es heute besser
aussehen können aber vielleicht noch mal
mit einem blauen Auge davon
gekommen danke schön für diese ersten
Eindrücke Alexander Pool sehr viel
besser wird die Stimmung sein bei der
CDU in Hessen Boris rein hat sich den
wählang gestellt und hat von den hohen
Verlusten beim letzten Mal viele wieder
gut gemacht 7,5 Prozentpunkte geht es
raus Steffen Schlösser Stefan Schlösser
ist da und da wird der Jubel groß
gewesen sein absolut hier sind die
Wahlgewinner zu Hause hier bei der CDU
Fraktion im häsischen Landtag der Jubel
war ja wirklich laut deutlich über 30%
im Moment bei 34 oder über 34% das ist
wirklich über den Erwartungen darüber
war der Jubel also sehr sehr groß man
hat auch noch gejubelt als als die
Zahlen für die Freien Wähler und die
Linken veröffentlicht worden beide nicht
im Landtag das stößt bei der CDU hier
auch auf sehr große Zustimmung gedämpft
wurde die Freude allerdings von den AFD
zahlen die im Moment in Hessen ja auch
sehr stark ist aber die CDU hat das
Wahlziel erreicht die CDU ist klar
stärkste Kraft der Ministerpräsident
Boris rin wird höchstwahrscheinlich auch
der neue Ministerpräsident werden und
kann sich dann eben in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen mit breiter
Brust reingehen und die Behandlungen
beginnen
ja danke schön Stefan Freude bei der CDU
in Hessen das sehen wir dann fragen wir
in Hessen bei der SPD nach da wollte
Nancy fer einen Erfolg einfahren jetzt
ist es das schlechteste Ergebnis in
Hessen in der Prognose bei 15% noch mal
deutliche Verluste Ralf also da
zeichnete sich vorhin schon die
schlechte Stimmung ab das hat sich dann
auch
erfüllt man hatte mit schlimmen
gerechnet es kam schlimmer wenn wir uns
die Bilder hier anschauen die Reaktion
auf eure Zahlen waren mucksmäuschen
still es war kein Wort zu hören
Fassungslosigkeit betrifft es
wahrscheinlich am besten dass man sagen
kann die Reaktion war wirklich geschockt
die Frage ist jetzt was war der Grund
Nancy fer wird ja gleich auftreten und
wird sich erklären und und Stellung
beziehen hier zu ihren SPD Genossinnen
und Genossen und sagen wie sie das sieht
wie sie es erklärt sie wird versuchen
ein bisschen Mut zu machen aber der
Situationsbericht kann natürlich nur
negativ ausfallen so
scherstärkste Kraft in einem Bundesland
D die SPD mal regiert hat nach 24 Jahren
in der Opposition wollte sie
Ministerpräsidentin werden nichts davon
hat sie geschafft nichts davon ist übrig
und so stellt sich natürlich die Frage
wie beschädigt ist sie wenn sie nach
Berlin zurückkehrt als
bundesinnenministerin und was bleibt der
SPD hier noch in Hessen übrig danke
schön real für diese Eindrücke SPD in
Hessen und wir haben jetzt erste
bundespolitische Stimmen ich begrüße
herzlich in Berlin den SPD
Generalsekretär Kevin küert guten Abend
Herr küert einen schönen guten Abend ja
das ist ein miserabler Abend für die SPD
vermutlich hatten sie das schon ein
bisschen erwartet
in Bayern Rang 5 hinter der AFD die auf
Rang 2 hochschießt in Hessen weiter
verloren ein neuer historischer
Tiefstwert wie werten sie das auch als
eine Quittung für die Regierungspolitik
der Ampel und den SPD-Kanzler Olaf
Scholz
zunächst gehören sich glaube ich zwei
Dinge an diesem Abend einerseits die
Gratulationen an die Wahlsieger an Boris
Rin und Marcus Söder die sich mit ihren
Parteien jeweils klar behaupten konnten
und das zweite was immer nervig ist an
Wahlabend ist wenn sich alle als
Wahlsieger sehen wollen wir sind heute
abend ausdrücklich nicht die Wahlsieger
es ist für uns ein bitterer Abend in
beiden Bundesländern die Ergebnisse
haben sehr komplexe Ursachen die
sicherlich nicht in ein paar kurzen
Sätzen zusammenzufassen sind aber wir
sind natürlich nicht taub und blind
sondern wir sehen dass die drei Parteien
der Ampelkoalition in beiden
Bundesländern verloren haben und wir
sollten die Signale alle miteinander in
der Ampelkoalition erkennen in diesen
Wahlergebnissen liegt auch eine
Botschaft für uns ja und keine positive
das werden sie sicher auch
unterstreichen erwarten Sie auch dass
das Regieren in Berlin jetzt noch mal
schwieriger wird unter diesen
Voraussetzung das Regieren ist in diesen
Zeiten schwierig aber nicht wegen zwei
Land agswahlergebnissen sondern weil die
Umstände schwierig sind das spüren wir
ja alle in der Gesellschaft es sind
krisenhafte Zeiten mit dem nun wie wir
seit gestern wissen mittlerweile zweiten
Krieg mit dem wir uns auch im
internationalen Raum noch mal neu
auseinandersetzen müssen das stresst
alle in der Gesellschaft das wirft die
politischen Prioritäten auch noch mal
durcheinander und unsere Aufgabe in der
Koalition ist es darin Orientierung und
Ordnung zu bieten und ich glaube alle
die in diesen Wahlkämpfen unterwegs
waren haben spüren können das ist für
viele Menschen nicht ausreichend erfolgt
zuletzt und
ja daraus müssen wir Konsequenzen ziehen
unabhängig auch von diesen
Wahlergebnissen am heutigen Abend ja und
das hat glaube ich auch Nancy Feler die
SPD Spitzenkandidaten in Hessen durchaus
wahrgenommen die jetzt hier tatsächlich
deutliche Verluste noch mal einfährt ist
dadurch auch Herr küer ihre Autorität in
Berlin als bundesinnenministerin
irgendwie beschädigt muss man darüber
noch mal
sprechen das sehe ich ausdrücklich
anders und da kann ich auch für die
gesamte SPD Parteispitze sprechen die
Menschen in Hessen haben heute ein
landespolitisches Votum abgegeben wir
hätten uns ein anderes Ergebnis
gewünscht aber es ist so wie es ist aber
mit diesem Ergebnis ist nichts über die
Bilanz der bundesinnenministerin nen sie
Feser gesagt die zuletzt
erfolgreich Ergebnisse im Bereich der
europäischen Asylpolitik verhandelt hat
zu der viele Amtsvorgänger vor ihr nicht
in der Lage gewesen sind WN sie fesas
erfolgreich und stark im Kampf gegen
Rechtsradikale und ihre Vereinigungen
unserer Gesellschaft und an dieser
Zwischenbilanz ihrer Amtszeit nach kaum
zwei Jahren hat sich mit dem heutigen
Abend nichts geändert sie hat unseren
klaren Rückhalt als
bundesinnenministerin klarer Rückhalt
und sie wird jetzt nach Berlin
zurückkehren vielen Dank Herr künnert
die Ampel sagen sie hat die Botschaft
gehört vielen Dank für dieses erste
Statement so wir schauen noch mal die
AFD ist Wahlgewinner des heutigen Abends
Rang 2 in beiden Ländern in Bayern und
in Hessen und die Bundesvorsitzende ist
in Wiesbaden ein erstes Statement hören
wirwerte für die AFD in Hessen und in
Bayern danke an euch danke an Hessen an
alle Wahlkämpfer in Hessen und Bayern
das wart ihr
[Applaus]
danke vielen herzlichen Dank auch an
denierten Wahlkämpfer hier rechts neben
mir Robert
[Applaus]
lambru ein Danke schön auch an die
engagierten Wahlkämpfer in Bayern an die
Spitzenkandidatin Katrin Ebner Steiner
und an den Spitzenkandidaten Martin
[Applaus]
böm
liebe Freunde wir können wirklich alle
extrem stolz sein auf dieses Ergebnis
heute abend es ist zwar nur eine
Prognose aber die Prognose ist so gut
die toppt alles aus der Vergangenheit
wir sind auf dem richtigen
Weg so
eined
die sich freut und stolz ist auf die
Ergebnisse in beiden Ländern Rang 2 und
das ist eine schlechte Nachricht für die
Grünen Bundesvorsitzende Ricarda lang
die jetzt bei uns im Studio ist schön
guten Abend Frau Frau lang ja also in
Hessen haben wir 15,5 Verluste in Bayern
haben wir für die Grünen ebenfalls 155
auch das sind Verluste also sehen Sie
das auch als eine Art Quittung für
Bundespolitik erstmal möchte die Chance
nutzen den beiden wahlziegern Boris rin
Markus Söder zu gratulieren und ich
glaube als grüne können wir sagen dass
wir zwei stabile Ergebnisse haben wir
haben zweimal das historisch zweitbeste
Ergebnis in unserer Geschichte in Bayern
noch die Chance auf Platz 2 zu kommen
das heißt wir haben gezeigt dass wir im
ganzen Land verankert sind und das ist
eine gute Basis um in Zukunft noch mehr
auszugreifen und ich glaube nach diesen
Wochen dieses wahlkamps gerade hier in
Bayern kann man sagen wir standen im
Zentrum der Debatte das ist aber keine
Position die wir scheuen sondern wir
nehmen diese Position gerne an um ihr
heraus Orientierung zu geben und für die
Menschen im Land zu erreichen also s
sagen im Grunde ist es nicht so schlimm
gekommen wie es hätte kommen können aber
die Höhenflüge sind ja doch vorbei Tarik
alvasir in Hessen wollte eigentlich
Ministerpräsident werden danach sieht's
nun gar nicht mehr aus wie gesagt es
sind stabile Ergebnisse auch wenn es
nicht das ist was wir uns vielleicht
gewünscht hätten was wir aber
tatsächlich besorgt dieser regingen zu
anschauen müssen ist dass natürlich alle
ampelparteien in der Gesamtheit nicht
dazu gewinnen könnten das heißt ich
glaube jetzt geht es darum dass wir als
Ampel schauen wie wir hier auch wieder
Vertrauen dazu zugewinnen können wir
zeigen können dass wir die Kompetenz
haben um die Probleme der Menschen zu
lösen aber für uns kann ich heute abend
als grünes sagen ich denke dass sich der
Kurs dabei auf Konstruktivität zu setzen
auf die ausgestreckte Hand eher
Rückenwind bekommen hat und deshalb sind
wir bereit das jetzt auch gemeinsam mit
der Ampel hinzubekommen aber was sind
die Konsequenzen für die Ampel also
werden Sie sagen gut wir müssen uns
jetzt als grüne noch mehr durchsetzen
vielleicht auch gegen die FDP die ja äh
hier ein schweren Wahlabend erlebt was
sind die Konsequenzen wissen Sie wenn
ich im Land unterwegs bin dann treffe
ich bei den Bürgerinnen und Bürger wenig
die mich fragen Frau lang ist das ein
grüner Erfolg ist das ein gelber Erfolg
oder ist ist ein Rotter Erfolg die
wollen wissen was bedeutet es ganz
konkret für mich was bedeutet für meinen
Geldbeutel was bedeutet es für meine
Lebenssituation und Desh sollten wir
vielleicht mal davon wegkommen Politik
immer als ein Spiel des gewinnen und
Verlierens und wer hat sich am Ende
durchgesetzt sondern wir müssen es
gemeinsam als Ampel hinbekommen Lösung
für die Probleme der Menschen im Land zu
gewinnen das ist auch eine Aufgabe wenn
wir auf die gestiegenen Werte der AFD
schauen das muss man ganz klar sagen die
können jedem Demokrat jeder Demokrat in
diesem Land nur Sorge machen da wünsche
ich mir dass wir davon wegkommen
Schuldzuweisung Floskeln sononder jede
demokratische Partei jetzt überlegt was
können wir tun um das in der Zukunft
wieder anders aussehen zu lassen ganz
kurz noch in Hessen können Sie weiter
regieren wenn Boris Rhein sie erwählt in
Bayern werden sie es auch anstreben
werden sie bei Söder mal anklopfen und
sagen es würde auch mit uns reichen wir
stehen bereit Verantwortung zu
übernehmen auch hier in Bayern ich denke
es würde Bayern gut tun ein Landes
Regierung mit Anstand zu haben die die
Probleme nicht nur aussit sonder angeht
und ich finde es wäre auch anständig von
Markus sder und so einer Situation mit
allen demokratischen Parteien zu
sprechen vielen Dank rard lang für den
Besuch ins Studio und wir bleiben noch
bei den Grünen und können bei Wolf
schmiese nachfragen wie das
grünenergebnis in Bayern aufgenommen
wurde also man hörte hier die Steine aus
den Herzen knallen also da fiel den
wirklichen Stein vom Herzen dass sie
eben nicht abgestürzt sind obwohl sie
Verluste haben haben und zwar bei uns in
der ZDF Prognose wie auch in der ARD den
Jubel den wir sehen der bezogt sich auf
die ARD Prognose da sind sie auf Platz 2
bei uns sind Sie ja ganz knapp auf Platz
3 und hier ist es jetzt so ein bisschen
bangen und hoffen dass Platz 2 sich noch
im Laufe des Abends verwirklicht es
werden hier schon Drinks gereicht
gintonic mit dampfendem Trockeneis also
die sind wirklich und das sagte mir
gerade einer der hinter mir steht
wirklich erleichtert dass es so gekommen
ist man hat offenbar mit Schlimmerem für
die Grünen gerechnet ja vielen Dank Wolf
schmese für diese Eindrücke samt
Trockeneis ja wir gucken noch mal in der
Tat in der Prognose Bayern grüne derzeit
bei
15,5 das wäre Rang 3 AFD 16 Rang 2 das
kann sich auch noch mal verschieben aber
so ist die Prognose der Forschungsgruppe
Wahlen hier bei uns und für die Union
weißt sie
in Hessen starke zugewinner aus
34,5 für
Boris rin die CSU in Bayern bei 365 und
leichten Verlusten aber in beiden
Ländern wird der Ministerpräsident
dererselbe bleiben ich bin jetzt in
Berlin verbunden mit cararsten Linnemann
er ist der CDU Generalsekretär schön
guten Abend
herlenann hallo Frau Schausten ich gr so
sie werden auf Bayern schauen aber mehr
noch werden sie auf den CDU Erfolg nehme
ich an von Boris reschauen und damit
sehr zufrieden
sein ja ein sensationelles Ergebnis ich
meine es ist kein Tag zum feiern wir
sehen das mit Blick auf Israel waren
eben noch mit Friedrich Merz auch beim
Brandenburger Tor das nimmt ein schon
mit stellt vieles in den Schatten
trotzdem klar das Ergebnis ist
sensationell der Boris rein hat einen
sensationellen Wahlkampf gemacht
fehlerfrei klare themenfokussierung und
die CDU Hessen war geschlossen genauso
muss es sein insofern ein Glückwunsch
nach
Hessen stellen Sie heraus für Boris rin
ist es auch ein Erfolg für Friedrich
märz also hat auch die Bundespartei
etwas
davon der Erfolg liegt erstmal in Hessen
wir haben unterstützt Friedrich merärz
hat viele Wahlkampfveranstaltungen
gehabt in Hessen ich habe auch
unterstützt und viele andere auch von
der Bundespolizei von der Bundespolitik
äh aber es liegt in Hessen aber sie
sehen schon der Versprecher
Bundespolizei ist ist Frau Feser der
Bundeskanzler muss sich die Frage
stellen wie lange sich das noch gefallen
lassen kann frau Feser wurde abgestraft
sie hört nicht auf die Bundespolizei um
beispielsweise auch Grenzkontrollen
jetzt einzuführen stationäre wir haben
eine riesen
migrationskrise und sie macht Wahlkampf
in Hessen sie hat Glaubwürdigkeit
verspielt und das ist ein Punkt den ich
gerne setzen will es geht hier wirklich
auch um die Bürger ich sag das jetzt
auch als Staatsbürger diese
migrationskrise ist da und es muss
gehandelt werden und ich hoffe dass es
morgen endlich losgeht ja jetzt sind wir
aber ja durch mit dem Wahlkampf jetzt
geht's ja tatsächlich dass sie auch in
der Union und in der CDU das Ergebnis
analysieren und da ist schon noch mal
die Frage ist es hier ein Ergebnis in
Hessen trotz oder wegen Friedrich Merz
Boris rin musste sich ja ein ums andere
Mal vom Bundesvorsitzenden eher
absetzen Frau schaen es ist doch völlig
normal dass ein Oppositionsführer in
deutschen Bundes AG auch mal zuspitzen
muss Boris rin ist Ministerpräsident in
Hessen und wichtig ist dass wir diese
Migrationsdebatte in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft führen und wir sind einfach
überfordert jeden Tag melden sich Bürger
Bürgermeister Landräte und wir haben die
Hand ausgestreckt dass wir sagen wir
arbeiten mit der Regierung zusammen aber
Herr Scholz hat vor 33 Tagen diese Rede
im Deutschen Bundestag gehalten den
deutschlandpakt Angeboten und bis heute
kam nichts und da muss er sich einfach
bewegen und wir stehen bereit Herr
linemann sorgen werden und müssen ihnen
die AFD Ergebnisse machen die ja noch
mal stärker geworden ist in Hessen auch
in Bayern welche verorantwortung hat da
die CDU die Bundespartei zumal es
gelingt ihnen ja nicht die AFD kleiner
zu machen hat da haben sie die CDU hat
der Bundesvorsitzende die falsche
Strategie also erstmal 35% in Hessen + 7
8% Punkte das ist wirklich ein Knaller
also das ist heraus und wir sind auch in
Berlin auf sehr guten Wege aber sie
sehen auch in der Historie in
Deutschland auch in den 90er Jahren dass
wenn Flüchtlingszahlen hoch sind die
Politik agieren muss dass die illegale
Migration in Deutschland unterbunden
wird man hat das 93 geschafft mit einem
überparteiolitischen Konsens und genau
das brauchen wir heute wir sehen das in
Dänemark die Rechtsradikalen dort haben
weniger als 3% und das muss auch in
Deutschland umgesetzt werden wir müssen
jetzt handeln sonst geht dieses Land
ja wird so überfordert sein dass es so
stark kippt dass auch die Humanität vor
die Hunde geht und ich möchte gerne
Humanität weiter großchreiben und das
funktioniert nur wenn wir jetzt dieses
Thema angehen und wirklich dann auch
offen sind für diejenigen die wirklich
ein Fluchtgrund haben ein Appell an die
Regierung letzte Frage her Linnemann die
die K Frage will die Union nächstes Jahr
angehen Ende nächsten Jahres wenn Sie
jetzt das Ergebnis von Markus Söder
sehen heißt heißt das dass sich dass
Markus Söder sich für die
Kanzlerkandidatur
empfiehlt jedenfalls im Rennen
bleibt also die K Frage wenn sie damit
meinen Konjunktur dann sollten wir die
jetzt angehen der Mittelstand braucht
dringend Unterstützung und die
Wirtschaft auch wenn wenn Sie die
Kanzler Frage mein war jetzt ein
bisschen keck von mir formuliert dann
bleiben wir bei unseren Zeitplan nach
dem Sommer im frühen Herbst werden wir
diese Entscheidung fäen ich meinte die
Kandidatenfrage aber sie haben es ja
vielen Dank Herr LN danke schön für das
Gespräch nach Berlin so und jetzt
schauen wir hier in Bayern zur zu den
Freien Wählern höre ich gerade 14% in
der Prognose sind leichte Zugewinne im
Moment wä sie damit allerdings auf Rang
4 aber CSU und Freie Wähler könnten
weiter regieren jutter sonnewald wie war
die Stimmung bei der Prognose also hier
ist tatsächlich großer Jubel durch den
Raum gegangen obwohl die das Ergebnis
oder die Prognose noch nicht so gut ist
wie eigentlich die ersten Prognosen in
den letzten Wochen da hieß es ja die
Freien Wähler würden auf 16% kommen und
man hatte da diesen Rückenwind aus
dieser ganzen flugblattaffäre eigentlich
für sich gut gemacht aber so gut ist es
jetzt im Moment nicht ich habe jetzt
hier auch schon mit ein paar Leuten
gesprochen man sagt dass es daran liegt
dass die Ampel sozusagen versagt hätte
das wäre sozusagen der Grund warum es
die AFD stärker ist als die Freien
Wähler im Moment aber man hofft hier
auch noch dass im Laufe des Abends
vielleicht sich auch für die Freien
Wähler das Ergebnis noch nach oben
korrigieren könnte herzlichen Dank Jutta
sonnewald ja also wer wird da auf Rang 2
liegen in Bayern in Hessen ist ist
zämlich deutlich die AFD in Hessen ist
das SPD Ergebnis miserabel wir haben das
schon gehört und hatten gerade jetzt
auch schon hier bei uns im Wahlstudio
die beiden Stimmen die
SPD will nennt sie fäser halten auch als
bundesinnenministerin die CDU empfehlt
sie abzulösen jetzt
[Musik]
wir nenn sie fer die ihre Verluste ihren
Anhängern erklärt da hören wir mal rein
meine sehr verhrten Damen und Herren vor
allen Dingen Liebe Genossin und Genossen
herzlichen Dank für die große
Solidarität ich möchte als erstes ganz
herzlich denjenigen gratulieren der die
Wahl heute in Hessen gewonnen hat mein
gratulation geht an Boris rein und die
CDU in Hessen die haben diese Wahl
gewonnen
für uns ist klar und das will ich auch
in aller Deutlichkeit sagen das
Wahlergebnis ist sehr enttäuschend was
auch sonst
wir haben uns erhofft in diesem
Wahlkampf dass wir eine Landesregierung
anführen können wir sind leider mit
unseren Themen für eine gebührenfreie
Kita für alle Menschen in Hessen
insbesondere auch für die unter
drejährigen
wir sind mit unseren Themen zu einem
sozialeren Hessen mit bezahlbar Wohnraum
mit einer guten Gesundheitsversorgung
vor Ort für alle und mit der Frage auch
der Sicherung von Jobs in der Zukunft
leider überhaupt nicht durchgerungen und
deswegen ist es ein sehr enttäuschendes
Ergebnis ich möchte aber auch sagen sie
Felser die Spitzenkandidatin der SPD die
einräumt dass dies ein sehr
enttäuschendes Ergebnis ist für die SPD
Hessen sie wird jetzt nach Berlin
zurückkehren so so ich höre jetzt dass
Stefan leidfad unser Studioleiter hier
in Bayern Hubert eiwanger im Gespräch
hat der vizeministerpräsident bisher
jedenfalls Stefan bitte so ist es petina
Hubert eiwanger ist bei mir Chef der
Freien Wähler und einer der Gewinner des
heutigen Abends guten Abend
herrwangerwanger was machen Sie jetzt
mit dieser neuen Stärke fordern sie in
den koalitionsverhandlung ein
Ministerium mehr also wir freuen un sehr
und großer Dank an die Wählerinnen und
Wähler die uns wirklich in dieser
schwierigen Zeit auch unterstützt haben
al ein deutliches Plus auf 14% das ist
ein Traumergebnis für uns jetzt schauen
wir natürlich wie die Zahlen dann
endgültig aussehen und dann beginnen wir
zu rechnen und zu verhandeln aber wir
sind hoch auf zufrieden heute als
freiewähler ist das Ziel ein Ministerium
mehr
natürlich hätten wir das gerne schauen
wir mal ob die Zahlen das hergeben sie
wollen ja auch im Bund an diesen Erfolg
anknüpfen könnte es also sein dass
Bayern nur eine halbe Legislaturperiode
Hubert eiwanger hier hat und sie dann
nach Berlin gehen also das ist ein Thema
das wir erst übermorgen diskutieren
werden also in einigen Jahren in einigen
Monaten zunächst mal Frau freut mich
auch dass unsere häischen Freunde
zugelegt haben auf mindestens 3,5% ist
auch ein sehr ordentliches Ergebnis und
dann schauen wir weiter nach Berlin
vielen Dank herwanger hubertwanger war
das und damit zurück zu euch in Studio
ber ja vielen Dank Freie Wähler mit +
2,4 in der Prognose und jetzt hö ich
haben wir eine Hochrechnung eine erste
und zwar für Hessen matthas so sieht's
aus die schauen wir uns jetzt an erste
Hochrechnung kurz vor 6:30 da sehen wir
die CDU in Hessen bei
34,7% mit sehr deutlich zugewinnen die
Grünen kommen auf 15,5 mit Verlusten die
SPD ähnlich große Verluste 15,2 die AFD
würde demnach zweitstärkste Kraft
16,8% mit deutlichen Zugewinnen und die
FDP nach wie vor bei 5% da kann man
nicht klar sagen ob sie drin ist oder
nicht im Parlament die Linke mit 3,5%
nicht die Freien Wähler mit 3,5%
ebenfalls nicht und die anderen
insgesamt
5,8%. die Sitzverteilung bei 102 33
sitzen die wir derzeit insgesamt haben
die Zahl kann sich wie gesagt verändern
im Laufe des Abends 53 für die CDU 23
für die Grünen 23 für die SPD 25 für die
AFD und
für die FDP wenn sie über die 5% kommt
was heißt das fürs Regieren in Wiesbaden
da sehen wir hier die amtierende
Koalition schwarzgrün kämer auf 76 Sitze
67 bräuchte man für die absolute Mehr
das reicht also ebenso CDU sp schwarzrot
76 Sitze und die dritte grüne SPD und
FDP wenn denn muss ich immer wieder
sagen die FDP denn drin wäre käme auf 54
und würde es trotzdem nicht zu einer
Mehrheit schaffen danke schön das war
die erste Hochrechnung für Hessen und
von dort aus Wiesbaden ist mir jetzt die
AFD Bundesvorsitzende Weidel
zugeschaltet Alice Weidel schönen guten
Tag nach Wiesbaden wir haben die
Ergebnisse gesehen die AFD ist der große
Gewinner des heutigen wahlabends Gewinne
in Hessen deutliche Gewinne auch in
Bayern wie deuten sie den Abend aus für
sich guten Abend Frau schaen ja das ist
natürlich sehr interessant zu sehen ähm
wie sich die Ergebnisse hier zusammetzen
ja wir haben hier klar gewonen das sind
Rekordwerte für unsere Partei für die
Alternative für Deutschland im Bayern
und in Hessen und äh die Ergebnisse
setzen sich natürlich zusammen vor allen
Dingen uns dass wir über die Jahre immer
mehr Menschen von unserer freiheitlichen
Politik überzeugen konnten Punkt 1 Punkt
2 kommt hier ein Sondereffekt dazu dass
das natürlich eine denkzettelwahl für
die ampelregierung gewesen ist die ja
auch eine Politik betreibt gegen die
eigene Bevölkerung eine Verbotspolitik
fährt zum Nachteil der Steuerzahler der
Arbeitnehmer und der Menschen die in
diesem Land leben sie sagen vor Weile
ein Denkzettel für die Ampel was macht
die AFD jetzt mit dieser Stärke werden
sie sich in Hessen Herrn Rhein in Bayern
Herrn Söder anbieten um
mitzuregieren wir bieten uns natürlich
an aber die CDU hat sich eine wichtige
strategische Option ja verbaut durch die
Brandmauer die Brandmauer besagt dass
man Millionen von wähln von vorne rein
ausschließt an einer
Regierungsbeteiligung und ich ich sehe
nicht dass in Hessen oder in Bayern die
CDU jetzt auf die AFD zukommt um über
eine Regierungsbeteiligung zu sprechen
das wird realistischerweise nicht
passieren ich werde ihn aber prophezeien
dadurch dass wir stärkste Kraft in
Ostdeutschland sind wird man im nächsten
Jahr wenn wir drei Landtagswahlen in
Ostdeutschland haben nicht mehr an uns
vorbeikommen und man muss die AFD bei
der Regierungsbeteiligung mit
einbeziehen ja die Stimmung in diesem
Wahlkampf Frau Weidel lassen Sie mich
darauf noch mal kurz kommen weil es alle
beschäftigt hat die war ja aufgepeitscht
äh es gab mitte ende September auch eine
Sicherheitswarnung an sie was
inakzeptabel ist ähm dass Politiker da
gefährdet sind mit Sicherheitsbedenken
wurde dann ja auch die Absage eines
wahlkampftermins Anfang Oktober in
Bayern begründet ähm da war von einem
safeeh die rede ich muss noch mal fragen
ihnen wird nämlich aus ihren eigenen
Reihen aus der AFD jetzt vorgeworfen sie
hätten ja eine anhaltende Bedrohung
simuliert den Termin in weit geschwänzt
weil sie Urlaub gemacht hätten auf
Mallorca wie gesagt das werfen ihnen
Parteifreunde vor haben die Recht Frau
Weidel haben die Recht dass sie
Öffentlichkeit und auch ihre Partei
getäuscht haben na gut also der Spin der
wurde ja medial damit
reingerührt fakt ist dass vor 14 Tagen
meine Wohnung mit samt der Familie wir
haben zwei kleine Kinder von einer
Antiterroreinheit geräumt wurde und ich
in eine sicher Sicherheit sichere
Umgebung verbracht wurde mit zwei
Kleinkindern sie können sich vorstellen
wie traumatisierend das gewesen ist ich
habe mich dann
entschlossen in der letzten
Sitzungswoche meine Verpflichtung als
Abgeordnete im Deutschen Bundestag
nachzukommen aber aufgrund der
Traumatisierung unserer Kinder habe ich
mich entschlossen mit meiner Familie
Abstand von diesen schrecklichen
Ereignissen zu nehmen und das mit
unseren Kindern
aufzuarbeiten und nichts anderes wurde
auch von meiner Seite aus kommuniziert
okay dann haben sie das klargestellt und
dann waren sie aber sicherlich auch
nicht zufrieden dass Parteifreunde
ihrerseits erklärt hätten sie wären zu
dem Zeitpunkt des abgesagten Termins in
einem safeehus was ja wie sie einräumen
tatsächlich nicht stimmte das waren dann
also Falschmeldungen aus der AFD das
sind definitiv Falschmeldung gewesen das
klären wir aber jetzt in der Folgezeit
intern auf Frau Weid nach diesem
Wahlabend der ein Erfolg für die AFD ist
bleiben sie bei ihren Plänen einen AFD
Kanzlerkandidaten aufzustellen und
stehen Sie dafür selbst zur
Verfügung das entscheidet natürlich bei
uns die Partei wir werden uns mit dieser
Fragestellung nächstes Jahr beschäftigen
wenn es so ist dass wir strukturell als
weitstärkste Kraft weit vor der
Kanzlerpartei SPD weiterhin zum Liegen
kommen dann ist es natürlich auch ganz
klar dass die Alternative für
Deutschland dass wir ein
Führungsanspruch Stellen werden damit
verknüpft ist natürlich diese
Fragestellung ich muss ihn aber auch
ganz klar sagen wir haben viele Leute
die qualifiziert sind um diesen Job zu
machen das muss nicht ich sein sondern
wir werden uns intern damit beschäftigen
wer überhaupt dort antritt und dann
werden wir die Mitglieder darüber
entscheiden lassen und ich muss ihn
vielleicht noch mal etwas noch mal dazu
sagen es hängt natürlich auch ein
bisschen davon ab wie sich die ganzen
politischen Verhältnisse in unserem Land
auch bewegen ich denke mal Ende des
nächsten Jahres sehen wir deutlich
klarer wie wir diese Frage beantworten
können das geht natürlich auch nur mit
der Option einer realistischen
Regierungsbeteiligung im Jahre
2025 dann darauf spielen sie vermutlich
an gab es auch die Landtagswahlen in den
ostdeutschen Bundesländern für heute
Abend vielen Dank nach Wiesbaden Alis
Weidel die AFD Bundesvorsitzende und
hier im Studio hat Matthias gänzende
Analysedaten zum Abschneiden der AFD ja
und wir schauen zurück auf Hessen und
auf Bayern in beiden Ländern stand für
die Wählerinnen und Wähler das Thema
flüchtlingeinwanderung sehr hoch und wir
schauen uns mal die erste Grafik an kann
das Land die vielen Flüchtlinge
verkraften das Sagen in Bayern 59% nein
in Hessen sind es 53% also Mehrheiten in
beiden Ländern und das ist hoch
interessant weil bis Mitte des Jahres
war das genau andersrum da hat sich also
etwas gedreht und auch das kann der AFD
genutzt haben wir gucken auf eine z
zweite Grafik was was erwartet man für
die eigene persönliche Wirtschaftslage
in einem Jahr die wird besser sagen 17%
die bleibt gleich 54 schlechter 25
interessant ist das ja aber alle machen
sich Sorgen und können sich Sorgen
machen egal welche Partei sie wählen
aber die Anhänger der AFD sagen mit
einer Mehrheit von 55% mir wird es
tendenziell schlechter gehen in einem
Jahr da ist also auch die Angst vor
sozialen Abstieg in Verbindung mit den
vielen Menschen kommen die der die
offenkundig in die Karten spielen ja
vielen Dank Matthias so und jetzt wird
reingerufen wir hören wir haben eine
Hochrechnung für Bayern das wollen wir
uns natürlich
anhören gut jetzt schauen wir wieder
nach Bayern und da haben wir die erste
Hochrechnung 18:34 Uhr die CSU
36,7% sehr nah am letzten Ergebnis s
leichte Verluste grüne 15,6% mit
Verlusten die Freien Wähler gewinnen
dazu auf 14 die AFD wird dem nach 15,8%
mit zugewinnen möglicher Weise
zweitstärkste Kraft das kann sich noch
drehen die SPD 8,5% verliert die FDP
sehen wir bei 3% die ist also hier im
Bayerischen Landtag nicht vertreten 6,4%
kleinere Parteien insgesamt die
Sitzverteilung Moment sehen wir 205
sitze wie gesagt
überhangsausgleichsmandate im Lauf des
Abends kann sich das Verändern nicht
aber das Kräfteverhältnis der Parteien
CSU 83 Sitze grüne 35 Freie Wähler 32
AFD 36 und die SPD 19 Sitze wer könnte
also mit wem hier in Bayern regieren die
CSU und die Freien Wähler das ist das
Bündnis was bisher regiert die kommen
locker über diese 103 Sitze die man
braucht CSU und Grüne auch das würde
reichen sogar noch ein bisschen
deutlicher CSU und SPD würde knapp nicht
reichen das ist im Moment der Stand der
Dinge ja danke schön und das können wir
jetzt direkt besprechen mit Alexander
dobrin Vorsitzender der CSU Landesgruppe
im Bundestag also sie haben eher den
bundespolitischen Blick auf die Ergebnis
schönen guten Abend Herr dobrend sind
sie zufrieden
36,7 noch mal tiefer als beim letzten
Mal richtig glücklich kann das nicht
machen wir haben einen klaren stabilen
Regierungsauftrag als CSU in Bayern das
ist ein wichtiger Beleg der Arbeit und
es gibt ja auch ein klares Votum der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zur Koalition zur
bayernkoalition von daher kann man an
der Stelle auch zufrieden sein
abgestürzt sind die ampelparteien auch
das sehen wir und ja das ert ist der AFD
auch das sehen wir mit Sorge ja äh
fangen wir mal bei ihnen noch an denn
sie sind erstaunlich genügsam also es
gab Zeiten in denen sagte die CSU alles
was unter 40 ist ist eigentlich
inakzeptabel ja die Zeiten ändern sich
natürlich wir haben Sondereffekte erlebt
in den letzten Wochen die Umfragen haben
uns ja schon tiefer gesehen diese
Sondereffekte wenn man die so nennen
darf dann haben wir die nicht zu
verantworten gehabt aber wir mussten
damit umgehen und dann haben wir auf
diese Schlussphase doch noch mal
deutlich zulegen können und jetzt ein
besseres Ergebnis als man vorher gesagt
hat von daher kann man da sehr zufrieden
sein und das ein gutes Ergebnis auf dem
man aufbauen kann damit muss man sich
nicht ausruhen sondern für zukünftige
Wahlen kann man vielleicht auch mehr
erreichen und Markus Söder ist
unangefochten durch dieses Ergebnis oder
nur am heutigen Wahlabend der Markus
Söder hat einen wahnsinnswahlkampf
geführt einen hochengagierten Wahlkampf
geführt gerade in den letzten Wochen
noch mal massiv den Druck der CSU erhöht
die Präsenz erhöht das hat auch mit
diesem Ergebnis dann zu tun und deswegen
ja wir sind da sehr zufrieden ist ein
klarer Regierungsauftrag für Markus
noch mal mit Blick auf Berlin sie sagen
Quittung für die Ampel aber hat
tatsächlich
nur die die Mängel der Ampel die AFD
stark gemacht was ist mit der
Mitverantwortung der Union wir sehen ja
eindeutig was die Leute emotionalisiert
es ist die Politik der Ampel es ist die
Respektlosigkeit wie diese Ampel mit
Bürgerinnen und Bürger umgeht auch
gerade auch im ländlichen Raum das
spiegelt auch dieses Ergebnis wieder da
gibt gibt es teilweise Wut da gibt es
Protest auf jeden Fall Unzufriedenheit
und die führt dann natürlich auch zu so
einem Verhalten wir reden da der Ampel
mit der Ampel seit langen darüber dass
sie aufhören soll mit Respektlosigkeit
den Bürgern zu begegnen und vor allem
aufhören soll diese Leute mit dieser Art
von Politik zu belasten das führt zu
dieser harten protestsituation wie wir
sie im Osten schon länger aber jetzt
auch in zwei Bundesländern im Westen
erleben ein bisschen im Wahlkampfmodus
sind sie noch wir haben gerade vom CDU
Generalsekretär Linnemann gehört dass er
eigentlich jetzt eher appelliert
sozusagen an ein Art deutschlandpakt
alle müssen sich zusammensetzen um die
Probleme äh zu lösen den Ton hö ich von
ihnen nicht schauen Sie ich habe als die
Regierungserklärung des Bundeskanzlers
war mit dem deutschlandpakt auf ihn im
Deutschen Bundestag geantwortet und ihm
angeboten Herr Bundeskanzler machen Sie
mit uns einen deutschlandpakt zur
Begrenzung der illegalen Migration bis
heute ist von ihm dazu nichts gekommen
die Ampel hat den Auftrag ja mit uns
gemeinsam was zu machen das Angebot
liegt seit langem vor wir hören aber
nichts nach den großen Worten kam das
große Schweigen das ist auch eine
Respektlosigkeit nicht nur gegenüber den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auch gegenüber
dem Parlament auch gegenüber uns als die
Mitte in der Opposition im Deutschen
Bundestag ja und es wäre gut wenn die
Ampel hier zu einem Bewusstsein käme mit
uns diese großen Herausforderung zu
lösen die Politik in Deutschland muss
besser werden dann wird auch der Protest
kleiner letzter Blick nach Bayern dann
hören wir nämlich noch Analysedaten aus
Bayern CSU eh schwach relativ gesehen
schwach dann gibt es die Freien Wähler
gestärkt dann gibt es die AFD gestärkt
man könnte meinen Franz Josef Strau
dreht sich im Grabe um oder CSU stabil
das ist das wordöring um das es hier
geht mit klarem Regierungsauftrag und
bei den unter den Bedingungen unter den
man jetzt Politik auch in den letzten
Monaten machen musste mit den
Sondereffekten in Bayern die auch mit
unserem Koalitionspartner zu tun haben
glaube ich wäre auch Franz Jose Strauß
mit diesem Ergebnis am heutigen Tag
zufrieden und würde sagen darauf bauen
wir jetzt wieder auf sagt Alexander
dobrin der Vorsitzende der CSU
Landesgruppe im Deutschen Bundestag
vielen Dank für den Besuch im Studio und
vielleicht haben sie noch Interesse
mitzuschauen die Analysedaten für die
CSU sehr gerne das schauen wir uns an da
geht's um die Bewertung des
Ministerpräsidenten aber auch der Partei
im Land und der CDU im Bund und das ist
die erste Grafik die Bewertung von
Markus Söder + 1,3 die ist positiv aber
weniger positiv interessanterweise als
die Bewertung der CSU insgesamt als
Partei die ist bei 1,6 man sieht also
schon bei der Wählerinnen und wäh dann
insgesamt wohlgemerkt nicht bei den CSU
Anhängern da liegt Markus Söder als
jemand der polarisiert hinter der
eigenen Partei wenn auch beide deutlich
vor der Bewertung der CDU und Bund
liegen hier in Bayern eine zweite Grafik
aus der wahltagsbefragung der
Forschungsgruppe Wahlen heute wer hat
die CSU gewählt nach alter wir lassen
das mal alles hochkommen diese Säulen
und dann sehen wir den mit Abstand
besten Wert bei den über 60-Jährigen das
sind 47% und dann geht es deutlich Berg
ab nach Altersgruppen und aufgrund
ohnehin schon schwacher Werte gehen hier
noch mal bei den unter 30-Jährigen fünf
Punkte verloren auch das ist ein Teil
der Erklärung dafür dass die CSU die
starken Verluste von vor 5 Jahren kaum
hat wettmachen können danke schön
interessante Analysedaten hier über die
CSU in Bayern jetzt geht der Blick nach
Hessen und zu Stefan Schlösser der ja
die CDU in Hessen heute abend beobachtet
und
da ist jetzt laute Musik denn das ist
der Einzug des wahlgewinners des
heutigen Abends Boris rin CDU
Ministerpräsident in Hessen er kann
deutlich dazu gewinnen heute Abend und
wird natürlich jetzt hier auch gefeiert
Stefan ja man sieht weder den Boris rein
noch hört man den Kollegen schon
untergegangen im trugel
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich
so bis sich unsere Kamera richtig
eingerichtet
hat und unser Reporter wieder
aufgetaucht hat aufgetaucht ist warten
wir mal noch da sehen wir Boris rin der
jetzt dem jetzt gratuliert wird von
seinem Vorgänger dem langjährigen
ministerpräsident Bouffier
und links sen wir schon auch kurz Roland
poch im Bild also da sind die Vorgänger
stolz auf
den Nachfolger Boris rein der sich ja
hier erstmals zur Wahl gestellt hat in
Hessen erst vor anderthalb Jahren
übernommen hatte von seinem Vorgänger
bffier und jetzt natürlich von den
Anhängern gefeiert
wird
[Musik]
komm lass uns
allesin schwarzgrün in Hessen Boris rin
hat diese Koalition als erfolgreich
bezeichnet durchaus er war nicht bereit
die Grünen als
Hauptfeind zu benennen so wie das die
der Bundesvorsitzende tut und jetzt
hören wir mal wenn man ihn zu Wort
kommen
lässt wie er sein Erfolg
begründet fres
liebe Freunde hallo und guten Abend hier
in wiesbeiden bei der CDU
Landtagsfraktion ich begrüße euch alle
ganz
[Applaus]
herzlich liebe Freunde liebe Freunde
vielen Dank für diesen wirklich überwtig
in den Empfang das ist einfach großartig
euch alle heute Abend hier zu sehen und
es ist ein unfassbar großartiger Tag für
die häische CDU für die
hessenunion liebe
Freunde liebe Freunde dieser
0 wird in die Geschichte Hessen
und eines ist ganz klar die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger in Hessen haben gewählt und
sie haben einen klaren Regierungsauftrag
erteilt und zwar an die CDU Hessen die
CDU Hessen hat den klaren
Regierungsauftrag der Bürgerinnen und
[Applaus]
Bürger und liebe Freunde das ist klar
und Bürger haben eines gewählt sie haben
die Hessens CDO gewählt und sie haben
damit Stil und Stabilität aber auch
sanfte Erneuerung gewählt das ist die
Botschaft dieses Tages das ist die
Botschaft des 8.10 Stil Stabilität
sanfte Erneuerung das wollen die
hessinen und
Hessen so Stil Stabilität und sanfte
Erneuerung da hat sich Boris rin etwas
zurecht gelegt wie ja ohnehin jetzt das
wording wie wir gerade schon gesehen
haben im Interview mit Alexander dobrin
ausgegeben wird am heutigen Abend und
bei der CSU soll das Wording heute abend
heißen nach dem Willen der CSU die
Partei ist stabil jetzt
höre ich das auch CSU Chef Markus Söder
Ministerpräsident von Bayern vor die
Anhänger tritt und auch da wollen wir
natürlich
hinschauen meine sehr verhrten Damen und
Herren liebe Freundin und
Freunde
ein langer
danke ein langer ein aufreibender ein
spannender Wahlkampf ist zu Ende
gegangen und obwohl es schwere und
turbulente Zeiten sind heute
außenpolitische eignisse die uns glaube
ich noch lange beschäftigen werden und
die uns große Sorgen machen müssen um
die Zukunft des Landes und der
internationalen Sicherheit kann man
eines sagen Bayern hat gewählt Bayern
hat Stabilität gewählt und die CSU hat
diese Wahl klar gewonnen meine
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr es ging
uns es ging uns nie um einen
Schönheitspreis aber um einen klaren
Regierungsauftrag und dieser klare
regierungsau ag ist an die CSU und ich
darfte sagen wie ich gesehen habe dass
über 60% der Meinung sind in Bayern dass
auch dieser Ministerpräsident gute
Arbeit macht sind auch ein klarer
Auftrag an CSU und mich persönlich eine
starke und stabile Regierung für und in
Bayern zu
bilden ich
glau Stärke und Stabilität zu erhalten
um unsere Demokratie zu schützen denn
das ist glaube ich die größte rausforder
vor der wir jetzt stehen einige freuen
sich radikalen Rand aber wir werden klar
machen wir werden dafür sorgen dass ein
demokratisches ein stabiles und ein
gutes Bayern auch in diesen schweren
Zeiten erhalten bleibt meine sehr ver
und
heren so war Markus Söder der CSU
Ministerpräsident der das auch bleiben
will und auch dieses wording genutzt hat
Stabilität in Bayern so wir wollen jetzt
aber nach Hessen schauen und zwar aufs
grünen Ergebnis die Grünen haben dort
Verluste
sie regieren mit Tarek alvasir der
vizeministerpräsident ist angetreten um
eigentlich an der Spitze Boris rin von
der CDU abzulösen davon war man am Ende
aber weit entfernt keine hohen aber doch
Verluste in Hessen und jetzt schauen wir
dorthin zu Tarek alvasir im Gespräch ich
hör mal rein wir schauen mal rein als
stat libe
Leute
li
danke danke danke danke für diesen
Applaus das tut gut aber ich sag's mal
so ihr klatscht auch euch selbst zu weil
wir haben wirklich einen super Wahlkampf
gemacht vielen Dank dafür vielen Dank
dafür
und und
ja Angela Angela hat's gesagt wir hätten
uns natürlich ein besseres Ergebnis
gewünscht aber wenn ihr euch diese
Hochrechnungen jetzt anschaut dann ist
das einfach so alle Parteien die an der
Bundesregierung beteiligt sind hatten
keinen Rückenwind und wir mussten Berg
aufkämpfen und ich danke euch dafür dass
ihr wirklich gezeigt hat dass wir auch
Berg aufkämpfen können noch mal vielen
Dank
dafür ja das also Tarik alvasir der
schon einräumt dass der Wind aus Berlin
ziemlich eisig kalt wete Matthias ein
paar Analysedaten zu den Grünen Hessen
das passt gerade ganz wunderbar wir
schauen uns das mal an die Bewertung von
Spitzenkandidat und Partei tareik
alvasier den wir gerade gehört haben im
positivbereich bei Plus 0,8 die die
Grünen im Land bei -0,3 also der
Kandidat hat funktioniert kann man sagen
und die Grünen im Bund noch negativer
-1,0 und jetzt schauen wir uns noch eine
weitere Grafik an ohne die Probleme im
Bund war die Aussage die wir vorgelegt
haben würden die Grünen besser
abschneiden das betrifft dann beide
Länder da stimmen zu
63% und die Anhänger da können wir uns
auch noch schnell anschauen das zieht
sich ziemlich durch auch die Anhänger
der Grünen vor allen Dingen sagen 81%
sagen ohne ein Negativ Einfluss aus
Berlin wär es besser gelaufen danke
schön Matthias interessante Daten so wer
zittern muss heute Abend noch das sind
die Liberalen wir haben ja schon von der
Quittung an die für die ampelparteien
gesprochen jetzt schauen wir auf die
Liberalen aus dem Bayerischen Landtag
sicher rausgefallen und auch in Hessen
müssen die Liberalen muss die FDP noch
zittern wir gehen mal zu Inken Klinge in
Wiesbaden ja bei mir ist jetzt Bettina
Star Watzinger Bundesbildungsministerin
und auch Landesvorsitzende der FDP in
Hessen in Bayern raus hier ist es ganz
ganz knapp woran hat's gelegen schadet
die Ampel der FDP ja erstmal gratuliere
ich den wahlsiegern Boris rin zu dem
Erfolg wir haben in Hessen einen
motivierten Wahlkampf geführt wir haben
ein Angebot gemacht das mit Optimismus
und mit Mut auch Veränderung anstoßen
wollte wir merken dass vor dem
Hintergrund im Augenblick der vielen
Themen die die Menschen beschäftigen
doch Stabilität
ein wichtiger Faktor war wir sehen
natürlich auch dass das
Regierungshandeln in Berlin sich auf die
Landtagswahl niederschlägt weil ja alle
drei Partner auch hier in Hessen haben
ein Bußen hinnehmen müssen und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger erwarten
Antworten auf große Themen wie z.B
wirtschaftspolitisch energiepolitisch
aber auch mit Fragen der Migration was
ja in den letzten Wochen heftig
diskutiert wurde und das wird die
Aufgabe sein in den nächsten Wochen hier
auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger ernst zu
nehmen ganz herzlichen Dank vielen Dank
starkziger und damit zurück ins
Wahlstudio ja danke schön Inken Klinge
die FDP muss in der Tat noch zittern 5%
noch nicht sicher ob sie in Hessen drin
bleiben im Landtag so jetzt wollen wir
um knapp 10 Minuten vor unserer 19 Uhr
Sendung ein bisschen schon mal erste
Bilanz ziehen Professor
Korte ja Stabilität haben wir gehört und
trotzdem ist ja hinter der Stabilität
auch einiges ins Rutschen geraten das
stimmt aber man muss schon sehen dass
die politische Mitte nach wie vor
dominiert in Deutschland auch die Bürger
als sicherheitsdeutsche das Interesse
haben ganz offensichtlich Amtsinhaber
wiederzuwählen das ist ein
wiederkehrendes Muster aber dahinter
sehen wir aber auch dass rechtsextreme
ein Rechtsverschiebung geradezu im
öffentlichen Diskurs nicht nur
zugenommen hat sondern sich jetzt auch
zeigt in dem wahlergibnis durch das
Erstarken der AFD jetzt eben auch in
Westdeutschland das sind ja Werte die
wir sonst eher aus den ostdeutschen Bund
Bundesländern kennen zeigt auch dass
sozusagen die AFD kein ostdeutsches
Problem ist nein sie AFD ist
gesamtdeutsch und im hessischen Landtag
war schon immer die stärkste nach
Prozenten vertretende AFD in
westdeutschen Parlamenten insofern ist
auch das ein Muster das scheint jetzt
wieder der Fall zu sein aber man muss
auch sehen dass ein Durchmarsch des der
demokratieverächter heute Abend auch
nicht das Ergebnis ist beide in beiden
Ländern hat sich die AFD deutlich
verbessert aber nicht so dominant jetzt
die anderen keine Regierungsbildung mehr
hinbekommen also man muss es abweggen
man muss es einfach einordnen es ist
sicherlich das Thema Migration es ist
Provokation es ist auch Protest aber es
ist auch eine ja zukunftsängstliche
empürungsbewegung also das zurückdrehen
der Zeit es in frühere Zeiten besser zu
finden das hat offenbar auch verfangen
in einer Zeit in dem viele
empörungserschöpft sind jetzt auf die
Frage wer ist dran schuld haben wir
heute Abend natürlich von der Union
immer gehört die Ampel ist schuld und
die Ampel räumt zumindest auch ein dass
sie diese Quittung die das da heute
abend gab auch annimmt jedenfalls haben
wir den SPD Generalsekretär gehört der
gesagt hat ja wir müssen jetzt uns
zusammensetzen und überlegen welche
Schlüsse man daraus sieht also wie stark
sehen Sie diesen Denkzettel diese
Quittung für die ampelparteien einmal
sehe ich wählermärkte bei denen Wähler
nicht grundsätzlich festgelegt sind auch
nicht für die AFD sofern gibt es eine
große Chance wenn wenige
gesindnungswähler da sind für die andere
um sie zurückzugewinnen und mit dem
politikergebnis beim Thema Migration
eben illegale Zuwanderung zu begrenzen
das Hauptthema was die anderen nach
vorne gebracht hat es geht um
grundsätzlich um eine gesprächsstörung
zwischen regierten und Regierenden wer
kann das authentisch auffangen offenbar
im Moment die AFD der CDU
Generalsekretär Linnemann hat noch mal
angeboten sich mit der Ampel zu
verständigen sich zusammenzusetzen wir
gucken jetzt mal auf ein paar
Analysedaten zur
CDU das ist ja interessant weil
interessanterweise Herr Linnemann nicht
das reklamiert hat als Erfolg für den
Bundesvorsitzenden März dazu gibt's auch
ein paar Daten ja wir fangen mal an in
Hessen und kommen dann aufs
bundespolitische also die Boris Rin und
die CDU in Hessen sind ein Wahlsieger
dieses wahlamts das steht fest und
deshalb muss man ja fragen sie haben
einen guten Teil ihrer Verluste von vor
5 Jahren wieder reingeholt wie konnte
das passieren woher kommen die Wähler
der CDU wer heute CDU gewählt hat der
hat vor 5 Jahren auch schon die CDU
gewählt das ist der größte Batzen aber
dann sieht man von den Grünen von der
SPD von der FDP von anderen und von
nichtwedern kommen die Wähler der CDU
von fast überall aber sehr stark mit 130
000 ungefähr von der SPD und eine zweite
Grafik über das was Bettina du gerade
angesprochen hast Landbund was bedeutet
das für das Abschneiden der CDU ist
Friedrich März hilfreich das sagen
gerade mal 17% er schadet sogar 40%
ändert nichts 34 bei den CDU Anhängern
sieht auch nicht viel besser aus
hilfreich sagen auch da nur 18% und die
meisten es ändert nichts also was sagen
uns diese Zahlen es ist schon ein Erfolg
der landescdu und des politischen
Personals des Ministerpräsidenten und
anderer und kein rückenwend aus Berlin
und da hat der Linnemann wahrscheinlich
wohl weilich nicht
den den Erfolg von Boris rin in Anspruch
genommen für Herrn März ja was sagt das
für die berühmte Kf in der Union heute
Abend ist Söder noch im Spiel auf jeden
Fall ist er im Spiel ich weiß nicht ob
er sich selbst noch motivieren kann nach
dem Ergebnis aber das Spiel macht nur
Sinn wenn einer überhaupt verzichtet und
der Parteivorsitzende der CDU macht
bislang nicht den Eindruck dass er bei
diesem politischen Lebensziel
zurückstecken wird nun war ja
interessant dass im Wahlkampf der CDU
Bundesvorsitzende die Grünen zum
Hauptfeind erklärt hat in Hessen aber
regiert ja die CDU mit den Grünen und
Boris rin musste sich da sozusagen auch
von der vom Bundesvorsitzenden
durchaus
distanzieren war das die richtige
Strategie ist das die richtige Strategie
für die CDU nein das ist die richtige
Strategie ist sich selbst mit Themen in
den Mittelpunkt zu stellen Problemlösung
anzubieten Wahlen sind ja ein
Versprechen auf Zukunft und welche
zuversichtliche Zukunft mit welcher
Problemlösung kann die CDU selbst
anbieten das ist das erste mit eigener
Attraktivität da scheint viele Bürgerin
und Bürger Zweifel zu haben ob sie diese
Attraktivität bestätigen können und wir
wählen auch immer in einer
koalitionsdemokratie Partnerschaften und
diese Koalitionen sollte man nicht vor
vorsorglich schon ausschließen mit
Landesregierungen sind die Grünen ein
sehr starker Partner im Bund und mit
vielen CDU-Regierungen zusammen eben
auch ein verlässlicher Stabilitätsanker
man wählt Partnerschaften ist es
eindeutig dass in Bayern die
Partnerschaft CSU und freie Wäller
gewählt wurde ja das ist ganz
offensichtlich eine bürgerliche
Gemeinschaft die offenbar sich ergänzt
das eine vielleicht etwas authentischer
als das andere die Freien Wähler kommen
oft daher wie eine gradswurzel CSU sie
sind eine heterogene Bewegung sie sind
vor allen Dingen für viele Bürger im
ländlichen Raum authentischer als die
anderen und deshalb attraktiv weil sie
einen antiparteieneffekt auch übersetzen
ein bisschen politische
romantikm was würden Sie sagen ähm ist
für Olaf Scholz heute Abend die
Botschaft dieses dieses Abends ja es ist
glaube ich von ihm erwartet worden aber
wenn er seinen Kommunikationsstil in der
Koalition und auch er selbst nicht
verändert das heißt mitnehmende
Zuversicht auch zu verbreiten Probleme
zu lösen anzunehmen die in den Ländern
offensichtlich sind wird es offenbar
schwierig also das ist eher ein
Zwischenzeugnis bei dem man sagen kann
Versetzung extrem gefährdet aber werden
die durchhalten zwei Jahre noch ja
sicher denn die sind ja eine stabile
Gemeinschaft sie werden ja
das nicht aufopfern weil diejenigen die
das aufopfern werden am Ende natürlich
abgestraft also sie sind gezwungen
weiterzumachen und es kann no eine
Dynamik des Miteinanders kommen sie
hatten sie in ersten anderthalb Jahren
ja auch unter Krisen und kriegsbedingung
wird die FDP die ja in Bayern
rausgefallen ist in Hessen sogar noch
auf der Kippe steht sich nicht noch mehr
profilieren müssen im Zweifel auch gegen
gegen die Grünen in der Bundesregierung
wird das Regieren nicht schwieriger
werden ja das ist so aber das wäre die
falsche Schlussfolgerung grüne und gelbe
sollten sich abstimmen was noch
erreichbar ist das würde der
Bundesregierung insgesamt helfen sagt
Professor karudolf Korte vielen Dank für
diese jetzt schon recht umfassende
Analyse wir haben
18:59 uh unsere 19 Uhr Sendung in Mainz
wartet schon während hier ich schon sehe
in den Kulissen unsere Gäste dann später
auch für die Spitzen kandidatenrunde
hier aus Bayern
eintrudeln interessanter Wahlabend die
Doppelwahl Bayern und Hessen andere
Themen aber sind in den Vordergrund
gerückt ich gebe jetzt nach Mainz zu den
19 Uhr heute
[Musik]
Nachrichten
die Nachrichten der